voilà grâce donc à l'ensemble des
journalistes de france 3 des reporters
nous essayons depuis donc le milieu de
l'après-midi de vous tenir au courant au
fur à mesure des développements de
apprécié triple attentat donc à new york
et à washington nous allons refaire un
point complet de toutes les informations
dont nous disposons à la fois en
information et puis des images et
nouvelles images qui sont d'ailleurs
arrivés il ya peu de temps en temps
quand quelques minutes new york a donc
vécu un véritable cauchemar il faut
préciser qu'à cette heure de la matinée
entre 8h30 et 9h delà des 9 heures le
quartier de manhattan est déjà en pleine
activité notamment donc temps l'eau ces
deux tours du world trade center ou
quarante mille personnes travaillent
vous allez vivre cette terrifiante
attaque terroriste sur new york en
images avec pascal justice
la scène est plus incroyable que le
scénario de la tour infernale
tout a commencé ce matin à 8h40 3 à new
york
une première explosion a retenti en
plein manhattan
un avion de ligne avec 58 passagers à
son bord vient de heurter l'une des
tours du world trade center la
télévision américaine braque sa caméra
sur la tour en feu caen 18 minutes plus
tard un second avion apparaît dans le
ciel
il s'agit cette fois d'un boeing 767
d'american airlines détourné depuis
boston avec 81 passagers à son bord
il va percuter la tour jumelle de plein
fouet en direct devant les
téléspectateurs du monde entier
l'explosion est terrible à l'intérieur
prisonniers des flammes les gens
appellent au secours
certains cèdent à la panique et décide
de sauter dans le vide
s'ensuivent des scènes de détresse et de
panique collective dans les rues new
yorkaises
alors que le maire fait évacuer tout le
sud de manhattan
j'étais au 36e étage quand ça s'est
produit
c'était comme un tremblement de terre
chuck lorre l'immeuble était secoué tout
trembler tout est tombé par la fenêtre
c'est vraiment incroyable dans un nuage
de fumée gigantesque le building le plus
célèbre du monde va maintenant
s'effondrer
il est 10 heures heure locale la
première tour s'écroule après avoir
brûlé pendant plus d'une heure une demi
heure plus tard sa jumelle se désintègre
entièrement 40000 personnes
travaillaient à l'intérieur nul ne sait
combien ont péri des milliers de blessés
ont été dirigés vers les hôpitaux sous
un nuage de cendres j'ai regardé vers le
haut et j'ai vu le bâtiment s'écroule et
sur la ville tous les gens de la rue se
sont arrêtés et on pleurait c'était
vraiment la panique
il ya eu d'énormes explosions on ne
voyait plus rien on aurait dit une
tempête de neige et on a compris que ce
n'était pas de la neige que ça venait du
musée
c'est un cauchemar le bilan humain ne
sera pas connue avant 24 heures en
revanche on estime déjà les dégâts
matériels à plusieurs millions de
dollars
nous voici dans les sous sols du world
trade center juste au dessus du métro
new yorkais qui à cette heure était
bondée et voilà en surface ce qu'il
reste des deux tours jumelles symbole de
la puissance américaine ce soir new york
ressemble à une ville en guerre
dévasté par un bombardement images